your mom is 83 years old she's the one
that's in charge of your Facebook page
yes and I yes a tip of the cap to mom
and I might mom yeah but she's not
watching but anyway I'm just curious
I'm just curious you know that's a
people will usually want to get some hip
young kid to run their Facebook page why
your mom how did that happen what
happened I did have a Facebook still
have but my mother was obsessed upset
because she wanted to make sure that all
my fans are happy and since she was 16
she was working the factory so you know
she likes to work work work but I know
at 88 years old
79 she asked me but sometimes you know
some fans or no fans they are sending
some nasty letters and stuff like it's
inevitable it can hurt your mother no
yeah and then she feel bad for her heart
probably feels worse than you do yeah
yeah and she was insisting insisting so
I gave up and she blew my facebook from
10 to 25 millions oh my god yeah but she
know where I am when I'm traveling so
she sent me a letter and pictures I've
got to sign and phone calls to kids and
so it's very beautiful yeah she sounds
like she's really on top of an amazing
woman and I love you papa yes you too
papa to all the Mamas yes mom and dad I
have issues with you and I'll talk to
you later
something goes back to the 70s you know
what I'm talking about all right
you